The Baťa Skyscraper,
in Zlín, Czechia,
is a landmark of
architecture.
I know it doesn't look like much
by modern standards,
but this isn't from the
1970s or 1980s...
it was completed in 1939.
It was Administration Building
Number 21,
built to run the Baťa company,
which had started as a
small shoe manufacturer
and grown into a
huge multinational corporation
across dozens of different industries
with tens of thousands of employees.
And this building wasn't
just modern in style.
For a pre-World War 2 building,
it's surprisingly advanced.
It has air conditioning and heating,
adjustable for each floor.
It has a couple of small
paternoster lifts
for getting between
adjacent floors,
a continuous chain of cabins
that never stop:
they're very efficient,
just a bit dangerous.
And the boss has a
corner office on every floor.
Because the boss's office...
is an elevator.
The control panel is
next to the desk,
and we're going up.
However, only the
museum staff here
are actually allowed
to push the buttons,
so please this enjoy this
little bit of camera trickery.
The folks who are showing me around
didn't want to be on camera,
which is fair enough!
So I'm going to be
your tour guide today.
This elevator was built by Otis,
the American elevator company,
for Jan Antonín Baťa,
the head of the company.
And the technical side of this
is roughly the same as
any other large goods lift:
Otis have built much bigger and
heavier elevators than this.
Scaling up to five metres by
five metres isn't too difficult,
and the furnishings don't
add that much weight.
It does have a few
extra features:
two telephones, one for local calls
and one for international;
plus separate lighting and
air conditioning, but those were
pretty much all solved problems
for elevators by 1939.
If you're running
one cable for lighting,
it's not much more effort
to add a few more
to power some fans and
provide telephone lines.
But the bit that surprised me
was the sink.
How is there hot and cold
running water, and a drain,
in a moving elevator?
When I first heard about this,
I thought there'd be a sink
installed on each floor
and it would just line up,
but no, this moves
with the elevator.
And then I thought maybe there was
some incredibly clever plumbing,
like in that rotating house
I visited a while ago...
but actually there's just
a water tank above
and a wastewater tank below
and every so often
maintenance would fill that one
and empty that one
because sometimes the simplest
solutions are the best.
These days, it's kept dry.
Now, there is a story that
the boss would use this elevator
to always keep a watch on employees,
appearing at any time,
staring from his chair
out of the door,
but the guides here say
that's a myth.
And it doesn't
make sense anyway.
Because each floor of this building
is 80 metres by 20 metres,
and this is a corner office
with fairly narrow doors.
There just aren't the sightlines
to make that possible.
And besides, there's a big
light-up indicator outside
that tells you what floor
the office is currently sitting on.
It's not recorded whether employees
would ever just push the button
to call the office to their
floor as a prank,
I really hope that happened sometimes.
I couldn't tell you for sure
why this was built.
It's probably efficiency?
It is quite a long walk to
the main public elevators,
plus it's much more private,
rather than the boss riding along
with everyone else.
And besides: Jan Antonín Baťa
never actually got to use this.
Because the building was
completed in 1939,
by which point Europe
was at war,
and Jan Antonín had left the
continent with his family.
The history of him, and the
fates of the various
international branches of the
company after that are...
complicated.
Complicated enough that you could probably
get a whole PhD trying to understand it.
After the war, he was declared a traitor,
and he died in exile in Brazil in 1965.
But in 2007, the conviction was
officially overturned,
and in 2019, he was given Czechia's
highest honor for services to the country,
and there's a statue of him
in the park just over the road.
History is complicated, particularly
Second World War history in central Europe,
and particularly when
I just came here
to make a video about
an interesting elevator.
This building is now the main
government office for this whole region,
and a local tourist attraction.
And every so often,
someone still stops by
to service the elevator.